et pour parler de la situation des sdf
nous sommes avec jean baptiste eyraud
porte parole de l'association a droit au
logement
bonjour jean baptiste eyraud merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte france
première question elle va apparaître
toute simple comment peut-on se confiner
quand on n'a pas de chez soi
voilà c'est ça la question qui est posée
c'est à dire que on a toujours un nombre
très élevé de sans abri on compte au
moins vingt-cinq mille sans abri encore
qui sont dans deux rues en france de
manière certaine ainsi que vingt mille
personnes qui dorment dans des
bidonvilles ou des abris de fortune
et donc est par ailleurs plusieurs
dizaines de milliers qui sont hébergés
dans des autres dans des pardons dans
des gymnases dans des dortoirs et donc
dans des conditions qui ne permettent
pas de d'agir efficacement contre le
corps d'un virus et qui ne permet pas
surtout de les protéger
donc on a à peu près cent mille
personnes aujourd'hui en france qui sont
délaissés en réalité par les pouvoirs
publics
aujourd'hui ce soit à paris hier par
dont le conseil supérieur du coville de
19 a rendu un avis dans lequel ils
demandent au gouvernement de prendre des
mesures et de mieux prendre en compte la
situation des personnes les plus
vulnérables notamment des sans abri or
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que le
gouvernement traîne les pieds
aujourd'hui pour vraiment s'en occuper
c'est à dire qu'il a des outils
puissants à sa disposition qui
permettrait de d'une part de loger dans
des conditions convenables et descentes
les personnes qui sont hébergés
aujourd'hui et qui sont menacées qui
sont en danger dans les dents des dans
des structures dans des gymnases ou dans
des dortoirs mais mais mais ils ne les
utilisent pas de la même manière il
pourrait aussi trouver des solutions
pour ceux qui sont encore la rue non
comment faire eh bien il ya la
réquisition il ya la réquisition et nous
avons plusieurs centaines de milliers de
lots
man qui sont des logements destinés à la
location meublée et touristique donc qui
sont habitables immédiatement qui sont
d'ailleurs mis en location sur des
plateformes de type erp bi nbi et
compagnie et donc ces logements
pourraient être réquisitionnés et mis à
disposition des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans la rue qui sont dans
dans ces gymnases voilà il ya nécessité
de 32 trouver cent mille places 100000
peut-être pas cent mille logements mais
parce qu'il ya des familles avec enfants
etc
il faut sortir les gens qui sont en
danger c'est une question à la fois de
vie et de mort pour les personnes qui
sont affectées qui sont sans abri ou
c'est une question aussi de santé
publique il faut c'est un moyen de
lutter de manière efficace contre la
pandémie dont jean baptiste eyraud avant
de trouver ses solutions concrètes est
ce que les sans abri elle ne devrait-il
pas selon vous être considéré comme un
public prioritaire en termes de
protection au même titre que les
personnes âgées
bien sûr c'est ce que demande le conseil
supérieur de l'ue contre le coc vide 19
inquiets qui vient conseiller de
l'elysée le gouvernement à son plus haut
niveau donc je ne fais que citer ce qui
est préconisé
parce qu'ils sont les grands
spécialistes en france des moyens qu'il
faut mettre en oeuvre pour lutter contre
la pandémie
donc voilà alors maintenant le ministre
du logement lui bon bah c'est oui on va
réquisitionner des hôtels les chambres
d'hôtel
bon en attendant il y a toujours autant
de chambres d'hôtel qui sont vides dans
paris ou dans nos grandes villes
effectivement il ya plus de touristes
donc il ya des places à la fois dans les
hôtels mais également dans les logements
meublés touristiques qui permette qui
permettrait aux personnes pendant au
moins la durée de la pandémie de
l'épidémie de pouvoir vivre de manière
indépendante et autonome
1 donc c'est un cc important d'assurer
des conditions d'existence des cendres
et protectrice pendant la pandémie
puisqu'il s'agit
deux personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité j'ajoute que jean va t il
juste avant on parle de certains sdf qui
ont été verbalisés pour non-respect du
confinement une réaction quand vous
apprenez ça écoutez nous on a fait un
courrier au ministre de normande est
justement avec beaucoup d'associations
et de syndicats la cgt solidaires et de
nombreuses associations et dans lequel
nous nous interrogeons disons mais
allez-vous jusqu'à permettent que soit
dresser des pv contre les sans abri
c'est une honte c'est un véritable
scandale pour notre pays c'est une honte
des personnes qui n'ont pas ou se loger
on leur demande en valais on va les les
leur dresser un procès-verbal parce que
parce qu'ils n'ont pas où se loger bon
voilà c'est la double punition c'est la
double peine
donc maintenant il faut le taureau par
les cornes et agir de manière très
concrète et nous avons nous après les
apprenons aussi une triste nouvelle
aujourd'hui toujours le ministre de
normandie vient d'annoncer qu'il ne
prononcera pas de moratoire sur les
loyers or vous savez vous s'aligneront
pas n'oublions pas que beaucoup de
locataires aujourd'hui qui ont perdu
leur boulot ou qui vont voir une baisse
significative de leurs revenus et qui
sont en général n'oublions pas que les
locataires sont par milliers sont les
ménages modestes sur les classes
populaires et bien comment vont-ils
comment allons nous payer notre loyer à
la fin du mois c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons un moratoire sur
les loyers c'est des millions de
personnes qui vont avoir des difficultés
et qui risque d'être expulsé après
l'épidémie
donc il faut impérativement prononcé un
moratoire sur les loyers et prévoir une
baisse de 2 de loyer voire mal du
pouvoir même la suppression d'une loi
est de des loyers à la sortie de
l'épidémie or le ministre du logement
vient d'annoncer qu' il ne prononcera
pas de moratoire sur les loyers
contrairement à nos voisins allemands
qui ont dans leur projet de loi de lutte
contre l'épidémie prévu justement de
suspendre d'autoriser le
la suspension du paiement des loyers par
les locataires et de telle sorte à ce
qu'ils puissent ultérieurement à régler
leurs dettes de loyer merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup jean baptiste eyraud
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir je
rappelle que vous êtes un porte parole
de l'association droit au logement merci
pour toutes ces précisions